The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on non-linear finite
element analysis of solids and
structures.
In this lecture, I'd like to
continue with our discussion
of the use of constitutive
relations
in non-linear analysis.
In the previous two lectures,
we talked about modeling
elastic materials in non-linear
finite element analysis.
We talked about the use of
linear stress-strain loss and
the use of non-linear
stress-strain laws as regard
to the T.L. and U.L.
Formulations.
I'd like to now discuss with you
the modeling of inelastic
materials, in particular
elastoplasticity and creep in
finite element analysis.
Let us proceed as follows.
Let us first briefly discuss
inelastic material behavior as
we observe them in the
laboratory test results.
Let us then briefly discuss how
we model these laboratory
test results in one-dimension
analysis.
And then I'd like to generalize
these modeling
considerations to 2D and
3D stress situations.
So let me now walk over here to
the view graph projector to
share the view grass
with you that I've
prepared for this lecture.
The most distinguishing feature
of an inelastic
material is that the total
stress is not uniquely related
to the current total strain.
of course, for an elastic
material, the total stress is
given uniquely by the total
current strain.
For the inelastic material,
this is not the case.
And to calculate the response
of the material, we need the
response history.
We need to work with stress
increments and strain
increments throughout
the total solution.
If we look at the equation that
we will be operating upon
in the analysis, we have on
the left-hand side here a
differential stress increment
given via the elastic
constitutive tensor times the
total strain increment,
differential total strain
increment, I should say, minus
the differential inelastic
strain increment.
Now, notice that this here is
really is the differential
elastic strain increment.
Total strain minus
inelastic strain
gives us elastic strain.
Of course, always the
differential of course.
And this, therefore, is the
basic relation that we will be
using, that we are using,
in inelastic response
calculations.
Notice that I did not include
temperature effects here,
which would mean I would have to
subtract, in addition, the
thermal differential
strain increment.
Later on, we will also consider
such relation.
The inelastic response may occur
rapidly all slowly in
time, depending on the type of
problem you're dealing with,
depending on the type
of problem you
want to model in nature.
If the inelastic response occurs
very rapidly, then we
model it using plasticity
rules.
In other words, in plasticity,
the model assumes that the
inelastic strain increment
occurs instantaneously.
In creep, however, the model
assumes that the inelastic
strain occurs as a function of
time, and in fact, this time
scale here might be hours,
days, or years.
Of course, the actual response
is a combination of these two
phenomena in nature, and we
therefore use plasticity and
creep, or alternatively, we may
also use a viscoplastic
material model to model what
happens in actual nature.
In our discussion now, we want
to consider materially
non-linear only conditions.
In other words, we only would
focus on material
non-linearities.
We know that, of course, all
the information that we are
discussing can directly be
applied in an MNO analysis,
Materially Non-Linear Only
analysis, and it can also
directly be applied in a large
displacement, large rotation,
by small-strain analysis, by
using the total Lagrangian
formulation.
We talked in an earlier lecture
about the fact that
using second Piola-Kirchhoff
stresses and Green-Lagrange
Strains, we can directly use
the total Lagrangian
formulation with these stress
and strain measures to model a
large displacement, large
rotation response of materials
by using the same material
relationship that we use to
employ in material non-linear
only analysis, but with these
two new stress and
strain measures.
Well, this is once more
summarized here, that in other
words, in the total Lagrangian
information, we use the
Green-Lagrange strain component
instead of the
engineering strain component,
and the second Piola-Kirchhoff
stress component instead of
the engineering stress
component, and then we directly
can, with the
material relationship that we
have established for an M&O
analysis, directly with these
material relationships, we can
model large displacement, large
rotation, but small
strain problems.
Let us now start by considering
some observations
off the material response
in laboratory tests.
We only want to look at these
observations schematically,
and therefore, we do not
give any details.
We also note that regarding the
notation that I want to
use now, we will not anymore
have the t superscripts on the
stress and t superscripts
on the strain.
We will not have these t
superscripts when we look at
laboratory test results.
So whenever we have a material
law, a laboratory material law
that we're looking on, or
a material law that is
identified by laboratory test
results, or, in fact, a
material law that we will enter
into a finite element
analysis, I will not have the t
superscript on stress and t
superscript on strain anymore.
We will, however, use those
superscripts again when we
take that material law and
actually apply it in finite
element analysis in an
incremental solution.
The material behavior is
obtained by performing a
tensile test in the laboratory,
schematically
shown as here.
We have a force p up there,
a force p here.
There is a gauge length.
Given here, the initial
length is l0.
There's cross-sectional area
A0, and of course, the
engineering strain, notice I now
leave out the t here, the
upper superscript t.
I leave that out, as
I just explained.
The engineering strain at any
time is given as shown here.
The stress is given,
shown here.
Where l now is the length
of this gauge
length at that time.
And here we have, shown in red,
how the specimen actually
were [? deformed. ?]
Notice A0 here and
l right there.
So l minus l0 is really the
extension of the gauge length.
We divide that by the original
length, and we get the
engineering strain, the small
strain, measure that we are so
used to seeing in
linear analysis.
And here the engineering stress
that we are so used to
seeing in linear analysis,
as well.
So this is the test from which
we obtain our information
regarding the material
behavior.
And let's look at,
systematically, test results.
Here we have seen engineering
stress plotted vertically, and
the engineering strain
plotted horizontally.
And the test result that we
would have obtained are shown
systematically in red.
Notice fracture occurs
here corresponding
to an ultimate strain.
Notice that the test, of course,
is performed in the
tensile region in an
actual analysis.
We also want to apply a
constitutive relation in the
compressive region.
And it is assumed that the same
behavior that we have in
the tensile region is
also applicable in
the compressive region.
So we simply reflect this curve
into the compressive
region as shown by the
blue dashed line.
These are the test resides
obtained at a constant
temperature.
Now let us look at the effect
of the strain rate.
If the strain rate increases,
in other words, de dt
increases, we can see that the
test results would change
schematically, as shown here.
Also, there is an effect
of temperature.
If the temperature is
increasing, but of course at a
constant temperature, we perform
the test, then as the
temperature increases for the
different tests, we would see
that the behavior of the
stress-strain law is shown
here by these red curves,
schematically.
This is the instantaneous
response of the material.
Now let's look at the
material behavior in
time dependent response.
In other words, over
a very large time.
Now at a constant stress,
inelastic strains develop.
And this is an important effect
for materials when the
temperatures are high.
A typical response curve,
engineering strain, plotted
vertically here now, and time
plotted horizontally, is shown
on this view graph.
Notice there is,
instantaneously, of course,
inelastic or elastoplastic
strain that occurs.
That's the one we just
talked about.
And then with time, there is
an increase in strain, as
shown by the red curve here.
We talk about the primary range
of the creep curve, a
secondary range, and
a tertiary range
until fracture occurs.
This is a curve at which sigma
is constant and the
temperature is constant,
as well.
If we increase the stress, we,
of course, get an increase in
the instantaneous strain, as
shown here, but also the
actual creep strain
will change.
And that is indicated
by these red curves.
Once again, fracture up here.
And these are the results now at
a constant temperature, but
at different levels of
constants stresses.
The levels of constant stress
means here, one stress, there,
another stress, there, another
stress, and another stress.
But this stress is constant
with time.
There's also a very significant
effect off the
temperature on the creep
strength, and that is shown on
this view graph.
Once again, strain plotted
here times there.
There's an initial strain,
of course,
instantaneously reached.
That's the one we talked
about earlier.
And then at a very low
temperature, almost no creep
effect, as shown here.
Basically a straight line.
Then as the temperature
increases, the material
creeps, and of course, doing
this for this curve, the
temperature is constant.
For this curve, the temperature
is constant in time.
is also constant,
but at a higher level.
And for this curve, the
temperature is also constant
in time, but still at
a higher level.
And once again, fracture
occurring here, and of course,
sigma is constant, as well.
For each of these curves,
we have the same stress.
But a different temperature
here, then there, then there
and there, the temperature being
constant in time for
each of these curves.
these are some typical
laboratory results
that we would get.
And now we want to look at,
how would we model these
laboratory test results in a
finite element solution?
And let's look first at the
models we might use for a
one-dimensional stress
situation.
So we consider a one-dimensional
situation as
shown schematically here--
a bar under a load p giving
a displacement u.
Notice now we go back to
introduce our left superscript
time t, because we want to look
now at this [? grade ?]
times t.
The stress at any time is
given by this formula.
The area being constant, of
course, the cross-section of
the area being constant.
The strain at any time is given
by the displacement
measured here, at that
time, divided by
the original length.
Remember, we're talking about
infinitesimally small strain
conditions.
Let us assume also that the
load has now increased
monotonically to a final
value, p star.
And let us assume that the time
is long, so that inertia
effects are negligible,
so we can talk
about a static analysis.
If you look at the response
that we would
see, we see the following.
The load increases as shown
here, and here we
have the time axis.
Notice T star is small.
It's a very small
time interval.
And in this time interval, creep
effects would not take
place because T star
is so small.
If they do take place, their
effect is negligible.
That's the assumption.
So plasticity effects
predominate here, and those we
take into account.
And then from here onwards,
there will be no more plastic
deformations in the material.
Now the material will
creep with time.
And so all the inelastic strains
are modeled from here
onwards as creep strains,
and from here to
there as plastic strains.
Now let's see how we would
model these strains.
Here we see how we would model
the plastic strains in this
uniaxial situation.
Notice we assume a bilinear
material description, bilinear
meaning a Young's modulus until
the yield stress is
reached, and then another
constant value of a new
Young's modulus,
if you want to.
It's not really Young's
modulus.
We call it ET.
It's a strain-hardening model.
Notice that ET is generally
considerably smaller than E.
Typically it might be 1% of E.
So we're coming up here.
After the yield stress, we
have a constant Young's
modulus, and beyond the yield
stress, we have a
strain-hardening modulus, ET,
to describe the change in
stress as a function
of the strain.
Notice now that if we had moved
up to here and we were
to unload from this level of
stress, we would follow the
original Young's modulus in the
unloading that we had in
the loading.
In other words, here we had
the same E in unloading,
indicated by the dashed line,
as we have for loading here.
In our particular modeling
situation, we are coming up
here to the yield stress, then
we proceed, going along ET, up
to that point, and that point
corresponds to our time t
star, where P star
has been reached.
The maximum load has
been reached.
Notice that this part here is a
plastic strain corresponding
to t star, and this part here
is the elastic strain,
corresponding to t star.
And that is obtained by simply
dropping a vertical line down
from that point t star onto
the horizontal axes.
The stress is then given by the
Young's modulus E, that's
E, or the slope is E
here, times te at
any particular time.
In other words, we could
have here, instead of
the t, the t star.
At any particular time this
holds, and the total inelastic
strain is given by simply the
plastic strain, because
remember in our model, we assume
that t star is so small
that all the inelastic strains
can be modeled using the
plasticity assumption.
This assumption.
Of course, once again, these
relationships hold for any
particular point on this curve
here, in particular, the point
time t star, where these
are the values
that we're using here.
Now from time t star onwards,
we have creep effects, and
those would be typically
modeled as shown
on this view graph.
Here is t star, which is very
small, almost equal to 0.
And here we have the time axis,
the creep strain axis,
shown here, and here we have
a typical creep law that is
widely used in engineering
practice, the
power law, shown here.
A0, A1, A2 are constant.
That has to be determined from
the laboratory tests, and they
will change for different
materials.
Notice that the stress is still
generated by the Young's
modulus times the elastic
strain, and the total
inelastic strain now is made
up of the creep strain
obtained by this formula plus
the plastic strain, the
plastic strain already
identified on the
earlier view graph.
Another way of modeling the
instantaneous inelastic
strains, which we call plastic
strains, and the
time-dependent inelastic
strains, which we call it
creep strains, is to use a
viscoplastic material model.
And in this case, we have this
basic relationship here where
we say that the total strain
times a time derivative of the
total strain, is given by the
time derivative of the stress
divided by the Young's modulus
plus a fluidity parameter
times this bracket here.
And this bracket here needs to
be read as shown down here.
Notice it is equal to 0.
If sigma is smaller than sigma
yield, the yield stress, and
is equal to sigma minus sigma
yield, sigma is greater than
sigma yield.
This part here is the time
derivative of the
viscoplastic strain.
Of course, gamma depends
on the material--
on the particular material
that you're looking at.
And also, sigma yield will
change possibly with time,
because there might be strain
hardening in the material, the
same kind of strain hardening
that we have observed in our
plasticity description.
Typical solutions for the 1-D
specimen would be, if you have
a non-hardening material, in
other words, the sigma yield,
the value does not increase,
then we would have here in
elastic strain, and with gamma,
determined by gamma, a
viscoplastic strain that, of
course, varies with time.
And you can see the total strain
here is made up of this
elastic strain plus a
viscoplastic strain, which
also depends on gamma.
If we have a hardening material,
then the situation
for the total strain looks
as shown on this
side of the view graph.
Total strain plotted, again,
vertically, time here.
We have an elastic strain.
And with time, a viscoplastic
strain that, however, will
reach a steady state value,
an ultimate value.
This amount here depends on
the increase of the yield
stress as a function of the
viscoplastic strain.
Notice that also, this curve,
this red curve, depends on the
value of gamma.
As gamma increases, you are
getting a curve that goes more
sharply up to this green line,
this steady-state solution.
Let us now look at plasticity
in more detail.
In other words, how we are
more dealing plasticity
relationships.
plastic materials, phenomena
of plasticity in finite
element analysis.
So far, we've only considered
loading conditions.
However, we of course, in an
actual analysis, might have
that the material is loading,
unloading, again
reloading and so on.
So we have to look briefly at,
how do we take such situations
into account?
Well, on this view graph,
systematically, we see what
kind of load history
a material might
be subjected to.
Here we have a load
increasing.
Say, up to here, we have elastic
conditions, then we go
into plasticity.
At this point, we unload
elastically, and right here,
we go back into plasticity.
From here to there, plasticity,
and then elastic
behavior again.
So how would we model such
a load situation on
the material level?
That is what we like
to discuss now.
Here we show a material
assumption, or a material
relationship, that would
be typically used.
Stress plotted up, strain
plotted horizontally.
Here we load the material, going
to plasticity in the
loading cycle, in the loading
regime, and now we unload
elastically.
Up to this point,
we are elastic.
We now are plastic, and we
unload again elastically, from
the compression region.
Now notice in this particular
material description, we
assume isotropic hardening.
And this assumption means that
once we have loaded up to this
point, the new yield stress is
given by this value here.
And before we would yield
again, in compression,
typically, or if we unload here
and come back, of course,
intention, we would have to have
a gain as stress that is
equal to this yield stress.
So notice in compression, we
have this value being here,
the same as that one.
And that means we have to go all
the way down here until we
will get back into plasticity,
and at this point, we go into
plasticity, as shown here.
The total plastic strains
is a sum of this
part plus that part.
All of these are plastic
strains that have been
accumulated in the
loading cycle.
Notice, once we have loaded in
compression further, we have a
new yield stress, sigma yield
2, which is larger
than sigma yield 1.
So whenever we go into the
plasticity regime and load
further, our yield stress
increases, and that means we
assume isotropic hardening.
I should also point out at this
point that we make an
assumption of the bilinear
material behavior, namely,
bilinear in having one Young's
modulus here and one
strain-hardening modulus here.
If you have a complex
stress-strain relationship
measured in laboratory, you may
want to use one et up to a
certain stress level, and then
another et from that stress
level on to the next stress
level, and maybe another et
beyond that.
So you have a multilinear
description of
the material behavior.
We don't have time to go
into such details.
It's an extension of this
material description.
Instead of using isotropic
hardening assumption, we may
want to use a kinematic
hardening assumption.
And that assumption is depicted
on this view graph.
Notice stress, again, upwards,
strain, horizontally, total
strain horizontally noted, and
here we're coming up in our
loading cycle to this point, and
the unload now, same way
as before in isotropic
hardening--
the difference is right now
occurring in this regime,
namely our yield stress that
will make us yield in
compression is not the same
yield stress that we talked
about in isotropic hardening.
Instead, this difference in
stress is simply twice the
initial yield stress.
So we reach yield in compression
much earlier than
in isotopically hardening.
Namely, when the stress has
decreased by twice this amount
here, we come into the regime
of yielding again.
And now we would be yielding all
the way along here, up to
this point, and now we unload
elastically again.
Notice, this is now the
plastic strain that we
accumulate in the compression
region.
This is the plastic strain
that we accumulate in the
tensile region.
These were a few words regarding
how we model
one-dimensional elastoplastic
behavior, and let us now look
at the multi-axial plasticity
behavior.
How we model, in other words,
plastic behavior in
multi-axial stress conditions.
In that case, we need a yield
condition, a flow rule, and a
hardening rule, and I'd like to
consider now isothermal, in
other words, constant
temperature conditions.
The yield condition flow rule
and hardening rule are
expressed using a
stress function.
And very widely used stress
functions are the Von Metus
function and the Drucker-Prager
function.
The Von Mises function is given
on this view graph here.
tF is equal to 1/2 tsij
tsij minus t kappa.
Of course, we're summing here
over all stress components sij
where the stress component sij
is called the deviatoric
stress, and is given as
t sigma ij minus t
sigma mm over 3.
This is summing all the normal
stress components, in other
words, t sigma 11 plus t sigma
2 2 plus t sigma 3 3, and
dividing by 3.
This is the Kronecker
delta that we
encountered already earlier.
The t kappa value is
given here as 1/3
t sigma yield squared.
Notice the yield stress here
changes as a function of
loading, as a function
of time.
And in fact, we are here using
isotropic hardening
conditions.
In the Drucker-Prager stress
function, assumption we have
this equation here.
tF is equal to 3 alpha t sigma
m plus t sigma bar minus k.
Notice t sigma m is
defined as here.
Notice the sum here over all
the stress is ii, in other
words, t sigma 1 1 plus t sigma
2 2 plus t sigma 3 3.
That is t sigma i i.
And here we have t sigma bar
defined, again in terms of the
deviatoric stresses.
We will talk in this lecture
more about the Von Mises yield
condition, which is very
widely used for
modeling metal behavior.
The Drucker-Prager yield
condition is widely used to
model rock and solid mechanics
types of problems.
We'll not talk in this
lecture about this
condition any further.
Please refer to the textbook,
where there is a bit more
information given about the
Drucker-Prager stress function.
We will also use, in our
discussion, both matrix
notation and index notation.
In matrix notation, for example,
the vector DEP of
plastic strains is defined
as shown here.
Notice we are summing these two
components here for the
shear strains.
The stress vector is shown
here, and if we use index
notation, we imply
these components.
dep 1 2 and dep 2 1.
Notice, once again, in these
vector or matrix notations,
these two components are added
to get the total plastic shear
strain, 1, 2.
The basic equations are, then,
for the Von Mises yield
condition, as shown here.
This is a yield condition.
tF, t sigma ij, t kappa.
t kappa is a function of
the plastic strains.
These are the current
stresses.
And [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
yielding tF is equal to 0.
That's what we're saying here.
The equivalent for the
one-dimensional response, in
other words, would
be this equation.
Notice once again that tS is
equal to 0 throughout the
total plastic response,
throughout all of the yielding
that we observe.
The flow rule, and here we use
the associative flow rule,
because tF is here the same
tF that we also use
in the yield condition.
The flow rule is given
by this equation.
Notice we have on the left-hand
side the plastic
strain increments.
Here we have a scalar,
t lambda.
And the partial of
tF with respect
to the current stresses.
t lambda is a positive scalar.
In one-dimension analysis, we
would have that the plastic
strains 1 1, 2 2, and 3
3 are as shown here.
And notice, of course, they
only depend on the
one-dimensional stress,
or the one stress
that is only active.
And notice that the sum of these
plastic strains is 0.
This stress-strain relationship
is given here on
this view graph--
stress increment on the
left-hand side, elastic
stress-strain, material
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
go into the CE.
Here's the total strain
increment minus the plastic
strain increment.
The 1-D equivalent, in other
words, for the one-dimensional
stress situation, we would
have this equation here.
Now our goal is to determine a
CEP matrix such that we have
on the left-hand side the stress
increment, and on the
right-hand side, that
CEP matrix times the
total strain increment.
Of course, the kind of stress
conditions, yielding, et
cetera, conditions must
all go into the
determination off CEP.
Let us now look at the general
derivation of this CEP matrix.
This is quite a general
derivation.
It's also given in
the textbook.
You may want to refer to the
textbook as well while we
discuss this deviation
or afterwards.
We define these quantities here,
tqij being the partial
of F with respect to the current
stresses with the
plastic strains fixed.
We also define tpij equal to
minus partial F with respect
to the plastic strains with
the stress fixed.
These are two convenient
definitions for the
derivation.
If we use matrix notation,
we assemble in
this vector at tq--
we are writing actually, the
transposed here, just for ease
of writing--
these components are assembled
in this vector.
Notice we have 2 times tq12,
2 times tq 2 0 3, and
2 times tq 3 1.
And these tools here result
from our definition of the
plastic strain and stress
increment vectors.
Remember in the plastic strain
vector, we had the sum of Dep
1 2 plus Dep 2 1 components, we
got the total plastic share
strain assembled in that
plastic strain vector.
And because we have defined our
plastic strain vector and
our stress increment vectors as
shown earlier on the view
graph, we now carry these
two along here.
tp, transposed again,
is written out here.
We know determine t lambda
in terms of de.
That is our first step.
Because if we have this
relationship, then we can say,
we have the plastic strain
increment in terms of a total
strain increment.
Using tf equal to 0, throughout
the plastic
deformations, because we know
that our yield condition has
to be satisfied throughout all
of the plastic deformations,
we can directly write down
this equation here.
And with our definition just
given, we rewrite this
right-hand side as shown here.
And we also substitute for
dep, t lambda times tq.
Notice, once again, we have now
in the fourth fifth, and
sixth component of tq this
factor two, because of the
definition of dep
shown earlier.
Well, there's nothing else than
a matrix rewriting of
this relationship here, of this
right-hand side here.
And we now use this relationship
in our further
developments.
But before doing so, let us see
how we can rewrite this
left-hand side here.
tq times [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
t sigma.
We can write this left-hand
side also as shown on the
right-hand side here, because we
can substitute for t sigma
simply the stress-strain law.
The flow rule, of course, gives
us this relationship
here for the plastic
strain increment.
Hence, if we use what we have up
here and substitute for the
plastic strain increments, we
directly obtain what I'm
circling here.
Next we use what we derived on
the previous view graph,
namely, tq times post t sigma is
equal to what's shown here
on the right-hand side,
what I'm circling now.
And this together then gives
us an equation that we can
solve for t lambda.
Having solved for t lambda, and
I will show you the result
on the next few graph charts
now, we can substitute 40
lambda back here, and we get our
plastic strains directly.
Well, let's look
at the result.
Here we have t lambda, notice,
given in terms of the
differential total
strain increment.
And now substituting, as I said
just now, 40 lambda, we
get the plastic strains
in terms of the
total strain increment.
This relationship is
now used in the
stress-strain law again.
Notice the stress-strain
law is shown here.
And we directly obtain, by
expressing dep in terms of de
by the relation that we just
have obtained on the previous
view graph, we directly obtain
this final expression for CEP.
Of course the current stresses
go in there, and the current
material conditions
go in there.
And we will apply this general
expression to an example just
now, namely the example
of the Von Mises flow
rule and yield condition.
However, before doing so, we
know need to break, because we
have to continue our discussion
on a second reel.
So let us now apply this general
relationship here
which we just derived to the
case of the Von Mises yield
condition with isotropic
hardening.
In that case, yielding is
reached when the principal
stress is here on the right-hand
side, substituted
into this right-hand side, give
us the yield stress, t
sigma yield.
Or another way of saying it, our
tf function is given right
down here, where we have here
the deviatoric stresses
squared, t kappa
is shown here.
We had in fact this relationship
already on an
earlier view graph.
Notice that this relationship
on TF is really the same as
what you see up here.
But of course, here we are
talking about the use of
principal stresses, whereas here
we are talking about the
use of deviatoric stresses.
Pictorally, we can represent
the yield
surface as shown here.
In plain stress analysis, this
would be the yield surface.
In other words, t sigma 2 and t
sigma 1 are the principle of
stresses that are generally
non-zero, but t sigma 3 is 0.
Here we have the yield stress,
and on the right-hand side, we
see the [? general ?]
yield condition in
three-dimensional stress space.
Notice initially we have sigma
yield, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
radius of this cylinder, and
that radius expands with time,
and it expands uniformly, as
shown, with the green circle
here to t sigma yield.
In other words, the cylinder
grows uniformly, the radius
grows with isotopically
hardening.
Notice that for the plane stress
case, the hardening
would be stress by having this
ellipse grow, as briefly
indicated, by this green line,
which of course goes all the
way around it.
Let us now compute
the derivative
that we need to have.
First we consider tpij.
tpij was defined as
shown right here.
And simply substituting for tf
in terms of the deviatoric
stress components and the
current yield stress, and
differentiating, we obtain
this part here.
Notice t sigma ij is fixed.
Therefore, these are constant
here, and of course drop out.
We get this result, and all we
have to evaluate the partial
of the yield stress with respect
to the plastic strain.
That is achieved by the concept
of the plastic work.
The plastic work per unit volume
is the amount of energy
that is unrecoverable when
the material is unloaded.
This energy, in other words, has
been used up to create a
plastic deformation.
What we will do is use
this concept for the
one-dimensional case, and then
generalize it to the
multidimensional situation.
Pictorally, in the 1D example,
in other words, only one
stress component being non-zero,
one normal stress
component to be non-zero, we
have this stress-strain law.
You're looking at the
bilinear case, which
we discussed earlier.
And the plastic work is
simply obtained by
this integral here.
Stress times plastic strain.
Integrate it over
the whole path.
So this shaded area is equal
to the plastic work.
In general, of course, we have
the current stress times the
plastic strain and in
component forms.
And we are summing over
all the components.
If we look at the
one-dimensional case, we can
directly express twp as shown
here, in terms of the Young's
modulus and the strain-hardening
modulus, and
the yield stress at time t, this
one right there, and the
initial yield stress, that
one right there.
This expression here gives
the shaded area.
We can now differentiate and
obtain the yield stress
differentiated with respect
to the plastic work, this
expression down here.
Using this expression in all our
general multidimensional
dimensional case, we directly
obtain tpij.
In terms of what's shown here on
the right-hand side, notice
we take sigma yield stress at
time t with respect to the
plastic work corresponding to
time t, and then partial
plastic work with respect
to the plastic strains.
Substituting here, we get this
bracket for the sigma yield
with respect to the plastic
work, and plastic work with
respect to the plastic
strains is equal
to the current stress.
And immediately we arrive
at this final
relationship here for tpij.
Alternatively, we could have
also used the effective stress
in effective plastic strain.
The effective stress is defined
as shown here, using
the deviatoric stresses, and the
effect of plastic strain
is defined here.
Notice this is a differential
increment in the effect of
plastic strain.
And if we use these two
quantities, we can also obtain
tpij via this relationship, and
the result is of course
the same that I just
showed you on the
previous view graph.
Let's now consider tqij, because
that is the other
quantity we need.
And here we recognize we have to
take the partial of f with
respect to the current stresses
with the plastic
strains fixed.
We substitute for f, and we
differentiate, recognizing now
with the plastic strains
fixed, the
yield stress is a constant.
Therefore, all we need to do is
differentiate the product
of the deviatoric stresses,
and that is achieved here.
The substitute for the
deviatoric stress is shown on
the right-hand side here, and
recognize that the t sigma kl
differentiates with respect to
t sigma ij is nothing else
than the product of these
two Kronecker deltas.
Delta ik, of course being equal
to 1 when i is equal to
k and equal to 0 when
i is not equal to k.
And we also recognize that this
relationship here reduces
directly to that relationship,
and the whole right-hand side
then becomes simply the
deviatoric stress at time t.
With these relationships for
tqij and tpij substituting
into our general derivation of
CEP, we directly obtain this
CEP matrix for the
three-dimensional case of the
Von Mises flow condition which
isotropic strain-hardening.
Let's look at some
of these terms.
In front, we have the Young's
modulus and the Poisson's
ratio down here.
Young's modulus here, Poisson's
ratio here.
Notice here, again, Poisson's
ratio, the same way as we have
it in elastic analysis, here
we have now the deviatoric
stress component entering.
Similarly here, the deviatoric
And so on.
There's also a factor beta that
goes in there, and beta
is defined down here in terms
of the yield stress, Young's
modulus and strain-hardening
modulus, and Poisson's ratio.
So this is a general expression,
and let's now see
how good we use that
general expression.
Well, it would enter in the
evaluation of the stresses
from time t to time
t plus delta t.
We have a stress increment which
is added to the current
stress at time t to obtain the
stress at time t plus delta t.
This relationship here is
expressed as shown here with
the CEP matrix.
In other words, d sigma is
given as CEP times de.
Now, this integration has
to be performed at every
integration point used in
the finite element.
Here we're showing 3 by 3
integration used in an 8-node,
two-dimensional element.
And notice once again that this
integration has to be
performed at every one of these
integration points,
which of course can be
quite expensive.
So we need to perform the
integration as effective as
just possible.
One simple scheme to use is
Euler forward integration.
And without subimplementation--
I will explain subimplementation
just now--
without subincrementation, we
evaluate the integral on the
left-hand side here by simply
saying, let us evaluate CP
corresponding to time t.
Since we know the stress at time
t, we know the deviatoric
stress at time t, we can
directly evaluate CEP,
entering into that matrix
equation that I gave you on
one of the previous
view graphs.
You can get CEP at time t, since
we know the stress at
time t, and simply multiply
it by the total
increment in strain.
Now, this would be OK if the
strain increment is very
small, and consequently also,
say it leads to a very small
stress increment.
But in general, this
linearization involved in
using the Euler forward method
can introduce a too-large
error that we don't want to
see in the analysis, and
therefore, we use what we call
the subincrementation.
Within subincrements, the
subincrementation proceeds as
shown this view graph for the
evaluation of this integral.
Notice CEP, times t, times delta
e the over n, where n is
the number of subincrements,
once again.
This means that we now can
evaluate the stress at the end
of the first subincrement.
We use that stress, which
corresponds to
t plus delta tau--
tau is delta t over n--
to evaluate this CEP matrix and
multiply the result again
by delta e/n.
Now this then, together, gives
us this stress at the end of
the second subincrement.
And like that, we proceed to
forward march the stress over
each of the subincrements up
to time t plus delta t.
This is nothing else really
but the application of the
previous formula, the one on the
previous view graph, over
each subincrement, always
updating, of course, the
stress that goes into the
evaluation of the CEP matrix.
Pictorally, we have the
following situation.
Along here, we are plotting time
t we have here, time t
here, time t plus delta
t there at the end.
Here we have the subincrements
1, 2, 3, et cetera.
You know that by the dot.
And notice at the end of the
first subincrement, we have
time t plus delta tau.
At the end of the second
subincrement, we have time t
plus 2 delta tau, and so on.
The subimplementation
schematically proceeds by
calculating this stress
increment so that we have t
plus delta tau sigma, then
evaluating a new stress-strain
law, based on this stress,
multiplying by the
subincrement in strain,
total strain, to
get a stress increment.
Thus you get this stress, and
like that, you proceed,
forward marching, again and
again, until you have the
final stress at time
t plus delta t.
Let us now look at the summary
of the procedure the way that
you would use it in a computer
program, and that summary is
given on the following
view graph.
We assume that the strain
corresponding to time t plus
delta t is known.
We have calculated that.
The stress corresponding to time
t is also known, and of
course the strain corresponding
to time t is
also known.
We then, as a first,
meta-calculate a strain increment.
DELEPS is equal to STRAIN
minus EPSILON.
This is a strain increment
from time t to time
t plus delta t.
We use that strain increment
to calculate a stress
increment, assuming
elastic behavior.
CE denotes a matrix of elastic
material behavior.
In other words, in this matrix
go the Young's modulus and
Poisson's ratio, and of course
this one varies depending on
what kind of conditions,
plane-stress, plane-strain,
axis-symmetric, or
three-dimensional analysis
you're looking at.
But I think you know what
I mean by that.
Having delsigma, we calculate
tau by updating sigma for that
stress increment.
With this stress now, we check
whether the strain was
actually taken elastically.
In other words, whether our
assumption that we have made
up here was correct.
And that is done by entering
into the yield
condition with that tau.
If f of tau is smaller or equals
0, then the strain
increment is elastic, and in
this case, tau was correct,
and we return If that was not
the case, then we have to
continue in our solution
procedure,
and we do so as follows.
If the previous state of stress
was plastic, we set
this ratio to 0 and go to g,
because the whole strain,
then, was taken up plastically,
also in this step.
Otherwise, if this condition is
not true, we have to find
that stress value at which
yielding started.
And we do also by entering into
the yield function with
sigma plus ratio times
delsigma, where
ratio is now unknown.
Delsigma is known, sigma is
known, so we can calculate
from this equation here
the value of ratios.
And ratio gives us that stress
increment, which brings us to
initiation of yielding.
Having ratio, we update the
stress from sigma too tau, a
new value of tau, where ratio
goes in here, and we calculate
the elastic-plastic strain
increment, using also ratio.
And that is a total
elastic-plastic strain
increment here.
This value depth now is used
integrate out the stress
occurring during the plastic
deformations.
And that is done by the
subincrementation process that
we discussed earlier.
We divide depth into
subincrements DDEPS, and we
calculate this tau value
by cycling through this
subincrementation here, which
we described on an earlier
view graph.
And this then completes the
calculation of the stress
value corresponding
to time t plus t.
So this is a very compact
summary of how the stress
integration from time
t to time t
plus delta t is performed.
Of course, there are many
important details here that we
haven't really looked at in
depth, but I think it gives
you a summary that is quite
valuable, because it tells,
overall, how the integration
is being performed.
Let us now look at two
example solutions.
First, an example solution for
which we have prepared some
slides, and after that, an
example solution for which we
have prepared an animation.
Let me walk over here to share
with you the information on
the slides.
And here we consider the
following problem.
You have a rigid punch here
subjected to a load, lying on
an infinite half-space.
As the load increases,
plasticity develops down here,
and there is an ultimate
load, a limit load,
that we want to calculate.
In other words, there's a load
here at which there will be
very large deformations down
here, and the material can
take no higher load.
This plane strain punch problem
was considered by many
investigators, but Hill actually
predicted the plastic
zones, and also the ultimate
limit load.
And we want to compare our
finite element solution with
the solution given by Hill.
On the next slide now, we see
the finite element mesh used.
Notice we are only idealizing
1/2 of the domain, as shown by
this boundary here.
Notice also that we have moved
this boundary here and that
boundary here far enough away
from the load application.
Notice that we have
a fine mesh here,
a coarse mesh there.
In the fine mesh, we use 8-node
elements, in the coarse
mesh, we use 4-node elements.
And there is a transition region
here, there, from the
8-node over to 7-node, into
6-node, and then finally into
4-node elements.
It's an interesting
small point here.
There is an incompatibility here
between this element and
these two elements.
An incompatibility because this
element here, being a
6-node element, has a parabolic
displacement
distribution along this line,
whereas this element here,
being a 7-node element and a
linear assumption along this
line here for displacement,
only admits a linear
displacement distribution.
So there is small
incompatibility here, and
similarly here.
However, that incompatibility
we deem to be small, that it
would not affect the results
very considerably.
Now, in an elastoplastic
plastic, analysis like in any
non-linear analysis that you
would like to perform, I
pointed out in an earlier
lecture, it is always
important to start with the
linear solutions, just to see
how well your mesh performs and
whether you have any data
input errors, possibly, even.
It is good to perform first a
linear solution where you can
compare with analytical
or other results.
This is what we have done here,
and let me show you on
the next slide what we
have considered.
We have applied a point load
here to the half space, used
the same finite element mesh
that I just showed you, and
looked at the stresses.
At this depth A, below the
surface, it's 0.697 inches.
At that depth, we're looking
at the stresses along this
line here on a horizontal
line.
These stresses here are plotted
on this graph for
different components.
Sigma zz, Sigma yy, tau yz.
And they are compared with the
theoretical solution, the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
theoretical solution.
Notice excellent comparison,
obtained really for the stress
components, and this means
that our mesh is quite
reasonable, and we can
proceed with the
elastoplastic analysis.
Notice please that we have
used here two-point
integration, 2-by-2 integration,
for all the
elements, including the
8-node element.
We then performed the same
analysis, also one, using
three-point integration, and
these results are shown on
this slide.
Same picture here.
Here stress is as a function
of the distance from the
center line in inches.
Notice with three-point
integration, also excellent
comparison for the stress
components.
On the next slide now, you'll
see the elastoplastic results.
And here we see the applied
load, normalized by a factor
plotted versus the displacement
of the punch,
also normalized by factor.
And we see two curves here,
one corresponding to
three-point integration and one
corresponding to two-point
integration.
Now notice that the three-point
integration
results are higher
than those of the
two-point integration results.
And that's a very interesting
phenomenon.
It is due to the fact that the
three-point integration puts a
higher incompressibility
constraint into the mesh.
In fact, a too-high
incompressibility constraint..
This is a very interesting
phenomenon, but it is best
discussed in another lecture.
Notice that however our solution
results all give us a
horizontal line here for the
two-point integration and
three-point integration, and
certainly, the two-point
integration results
are quite close to
the theoretical value.
If we were to use the finer mesh
and still use three-point
integration, we would
get also closer to
the theoretical value.
Of course, we have here, I
should have pointed out, an
elastic, perfectly plastic
material assumption for the
material under the footing.
Please refer to the details of
this example solution given in
the paper in which we have
reported this sample solution.
And the reference to
that paper is given
in the study guide.
The second problem that I'd
like to discuss with you
concerns the analysis of a plate
with a hole that we are
subjecting to very large
tensile forces.
And there is one interesting
feature that we observe in
that analysis which we have not
seen here on the slides,
namely, the spread of plasticity
through the domain.
So let me introduce you to this
problem using just two
view graphs, and then show you
the animation which gives the
results to the problem.
Here we have the plate
with a hole.
It's subjected to tensile
forces, so you can see.
And we want to calculate,
really, the ultimate limit
load of the plate, and we want
to see now the spread of
plasticity.
Of course, that spread of
plasticity also occurs in the
analysis of the rigid punch on
an elastoplastic footing, but
I did not show you that spread
of placiticity there.
I'd like to show you
the spread the
plasticity now here.
And you will see that the
plasticity actually spread
through the elements,
integration point by
integration point.
And of course initially, as a
load increase is not so rapid,
but then all of a sudden you see
a very rapid spread of the
plasticity, right through this
domain here, that domain
there, and so on, by symmetry
conditions.
Now, because of symmetry
conditions, we also will look
at only one quarter
of the plate--
this quarter right here.
The material assumption that
is used in the analysis is
shown on this view graph.
Stress here, strain there.
Notice Young's modulus, as
shown here, Poisson ratio
there, and the strain-hardening
modulus is
shown here.
We assume isotropic hardening.
The same problem would also be
considered further in a later
lecture, when we actually use
the ADINA program to show an
application.
So you will encounter this
problem there again.
Notice that in this particular
analysis that you will be
seeing now, in the animation,
we assumed a materially
non-linear only condition.
In other words, we assumed
infinitesimally small
displacement and strains.
However, in the very last load
steps, just before the plate
ruptures, we encounter,
actually, larger strains, but
only those last load steps.
And in order to capture this
very last behavior of the
plate very accurately, one would
have to perform a large
strain analysis of the plate,
which we did not do here, and
which really would
be the object off
another lecture, as well.
So let's look now at the
response of the plate.
Yes, it is subjected to the
tensile forces and how the
plasticity spread through the
plate until final rupture.
Let's look at the animation.
We will look first at a fast
animation, where the response
occurs very fast, and then
we'll look at the same
animation again but slower, so
that I can better talk about
it while you're watching it, and
you can better understand
what I'm saying.
Here we see one quarter of the
plate discretized using 288
eight-node isoparametric
plane stress elements.
The time course gives
the load step.
We perform the static analysis
and the load corresponding to
each solution step
is also shown.
Here you see now the load
increasing, and in the first
load step, the plate
remains elastic.
Plasticity then developed as
a whole and spreads rapidly
through the plate as
the load increases.
The deformations of the
plate are given here
to a magnified scale.
This was a rather fast look at
the plate behavior, so let's
look at it again and over a
somewhat longer time scale.
Here we have again the
plate at time 0--
that is at zero-load
application.
Now the load application starts,
and initially, the
plate remains elastic.
Be sure that an element
integration point has gone
plastic by darkening the
regions around it.
Since we use 3-by-3 Gauss
integration, considering an
element on an average 1/9 of
the element [? area ?]
corresponds to an integration
point.
Here you can see how the
plasticity spreads from
element to element, and indeed,
from integration point
to integration point.
We will discuss the analysis
of the plate
again in lecture 22.
We will also perform analyses
and study the results,
including large displacement
and large strain effects.
Once again, the deformations of
the plate are shown here in
the animation to a
magnified scale.
The actual displacements are
discussed in lecture 22.
So this brings me then to
the end of this lecture.
I discussed everything I wanted
to discuss with you in
this lecture.
Thank you very much for
your attention.